двигуни польських леопардів вже
розігріть їм прем'єр Польщі Анжи Дуда
вчергове запевнив що Варшава готова
надати ці важкі вагою 60 тонн бойові
танки в Україні з децидовалістю
Ми вирішили що готові передати в рамках
міжнародної коаліції наш елемент
яким буде рота танків леопард
Леопард 2 у модифікації А4 ми будемо
прагнути на міжнародному рівні щоб ця
коаліція була створена широким колом
країн які зроблять внесок свої танки
броньована рота може налічувати від 10
до 14 бойових танків леопард вони
заправлені і готові ворушати Але перед
ними німець
Річ у тім що для реекспорту зброю як у
випадку з Польщею і Україною потрібна
згода уряду країни-виробника тож Берлін
ще мав би сказати так і надати дозвіл
Варшаві
те що ми спостерігали протягом останніх
днів і тижнів безумовно посилює тиск на
канцлера Німеччини це не лише майже
офіційний запит Польщі щодо реекспорту
танків леопарду німецького виробництва в
Україну але зростаючий хор голосів
Фінляндії Данії та інших європейських
країн які використовують ці танки
Леопард 2 вироблені в Німеччині нарешті
надати згоду експортувати їх в Україну
підтримувати Україну в оборонній
боротьбі проти російської агресії і
канцлер справді тут зволікає
свої зволіканні олафшольс та його
оточення пояснюють двома аргументами
прагненням уникнути подальшої ескалації
з боку Росії та небажанням Німеччини
діяти наодинці в питаннях постачання
танків тиск на німецького канцлера
зростає і Шульца піддається йому кажуть
оглядачі після того як США вирішили
надати Україні бойові машини піхоти
Бредлі а Франція танки на колесах mx10rc
Німеччина теж зголосилася направити в
Україну бмп-мардер схоже сценарій може
повторитися і з танками кажуть експерти
але перший крок Берлін очікує від білого
дому чимало членів правліча коаліції в
Німеччині вже прямо виступають за
надання танків в Україні зокрема зелені
Минулого тижня у нас відбулися великі
зміни в політиці Німеччини щодо важкого
озброєння коли Американський президент і
канцлер Німеччини заявили про надання
броньованих бойових машин піхоти
Я думаю що зараз Настав час поставити
також основні бойові Танки я був у липні
в останні в Києві І багато людей там в
уряді та в громадському суспільстві
парламенті всюди Вони казали мені що нам
точно потрібні засоби протиповітряної
оборони нам потрібна артилерія Нам
потрібні бойові машини піхоти та основні
бойові танки однак позиція завжди була
така Ні ми не хочемо загострювати це
питання але те що ми бачили коли ми не
надавали зброю це те як Росія розгортає
війну Ми бачили масовий терор проти
цивільного населення в містах з
повітряними атаками а також на
окупованих територіях єдиний спосіб
зупинити цей терор на окупованих
територіях дати Україні можливість їх
звільнити і щоб їх звільнити Україні
потрібні основні та БМП експерти
попереджають що Путін навмисно затягує
війну і тисне на захід щоб союзники
передумали підтримувати Україну тож
потрібна єдність
будь-які сумніви Які заходи демонструють
щодо підтримки України трактуються як
при відкритий вікно що можливо російська
кампанія тиском через енергетичну війну
через розпалювання нової міграційної
кризи шляхом руйнування енергетичної
інфраструктуру України та просто
загальних звірів може змусити західних
прихильників вагатися і скасувати деякі
зі своїх рішень або залишити Україну
напризволяще в якийсь момент коли ціна
підтримки стане занадто високою і тому я
вважаю що це дійсно Важливо не лише для
України а для того щоб ми сигналізували
Росії що ми чітко даємо зрозуміти що
наша рішучість непохитна і рішення
надати танки леопард буде частиною
демонстрації цієї рішучості
нині у 13 країнах Європи на озброєнні
перебувають близько двох тисяч леопардів
дозвіл реекспорту для Польщі міг би
стати прецедентом для схожих поставок
цих танків іншими країнами
віце-канцлер ФРН Роберт габбек заявив що
є різниця між ухваленням рішення щодо
себе та перешкоджанням ухваленню рішення
іншими політик від зелених вважають що
Німеччина не повинна стояти на шляху
коли інші держави надають підтримку
Україні